bill cosby goes free a columnist pushes
lgbt kink for children in the pages of
the washington post
and president biden is caught between a
moderate rock and a radical hard place
i'm bench bro this is the bench bureau
[Music]
show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights take
action at expressvpn.com
slash ben alright so the big news of the
day is that bill cosby is now free
according to yahoo news and reuters
reaction to bill cosby being freed from
prison on wednesday after pennsylvania's
highest court overturned his sexual
assault conviction
range from outrage to cheers here are
some of those voices time's up
foundation president tina chen said in a
statement today's devastating decision
to overturn the conviction of a man who
caused so much harm pain and emotional
trauma to so many women
is a travesty and an injustice it
reminds us again of the struggle that
the survivors of his predatory behavior
and actions
have endured to make their voices heard
the semblance of justice these women had
and knowing cosby was convicted has been
completely erased with his release today
now here is the thing there's a lot of
outrage today
about the release of bill cosby bill
cosby is not released because he's
innocent bill cosby was released because
the way that the prosecutors got him is
called cheating
and what they did here and this is what
the highest court in pennsylvania found
is they violated his due process and the
fact that there is so much
outrage over the vacation of the
vacating of his conviction demonstrates
that people
are just not capable of separating off
the notion of due process
from whether you think the person is
guilty or innocent or not
right whether you think that that
somebody is guilty or innocent is a very
little value in determining whether or
not
the person had due process and it turns
out that in in bill cosby's case
there are some pretty significant
questions about due process
so gabriel mellor has a good piece over
the washington examiner
explaining all of this because if you
don't understand the process you don't
understand what happened here the way
the media are covering this it makes it
seem like bill cosby walked because he
was
suddenly found innocent and that of
course is not true
according to the washington examiner's
gabriel mellor as a lawyer the
conclusion of bill cosby's long-running
assault case is not so much vindication
for cosby
as it is a vindication of the right to
due process more than a decade ago a
district attorney investigating one of
the many sexual assault claims against
cosby
determined there was insufficient
evidence to prosecute him and this is a
big problem in sexual assault cases
it's very difficult to substantiate
sexual assault to the point
of conviction because very often it
turns into a he said she said scenario
in which a woman claims that she has
been abused by a man and the man claims
that
it was consensual and that it was just
rough that that sort of thing happens
all the time for prosecutors
and so in this particular case the
prosecutor said we don't have the
evidence to get him but
they also wanted cosby to have to
testify at a civil trial
now the way that this works is that you
are allowed in civil trial to say
i am not going to testify about
something that could get me criminally
convicted
right so if if you were for example
being sued
on the basis of punching somebody in the
face and it's a civil trial not a
criminal trial
you're allowed to say i don't want to
testify about whether i punch that
person in the face because i could be
incriminating myself
and then i could be convicted based on
the testimony i'm about to give
so what the prosecutors in this case did
knowing they couldn't prosecute caused
me successfully
is they said to cosby in this particular
case
you know what we're not going to
prosecute you on this stuff if you if
relying on that promise bill cosby then
testifies
because the fifth amendment no longer
applies you can't claim fifth amendment
privilege against self-incrimination
if there is no possibility of criminal
conviction so for example
if you were called upon to testify in
court
that you had not gone to the grocery
store yesterday you can't test it
you can't take the fifth taking the
fifth has no relevance in that context
because you could not be prosecuted
for not going to the grocery store
yesterday right so
what what you do by removing the
possibility of criminal conviction
is you take away somebody's ability to
use the fifth amendment to protect
themselves against self-incrimination
that's basically what the prosecutor in
this case did and cosby relied upon that
promise
according to malor the district
alternate the district attorney
had an alternative to criminal
prosecution in the 2005 case he believed
that cosby's testimony could be
compelled in the accuser's civil suit if
there is no chance such testimony would
run afoul
of cosby's fifth amendment privilege
against self-incrimination so he made a
public announcement
that the case against cosby was closed
captioning not
would then be used by available new
district attorney who successfully
brought criminal assault charges against
cosby
and the supreme court of pennsylvania
said no you can't do that once you
promise somebody that they're not going
to be criminally indicted on a matter
and then you compel their testimony in a
civil case
you can't then go back and reverse
yourself and say you know by the way
so glad you testified in that civil case
about your guilt now we're going to take
that and we're going to convict you
the supreme court of pennsylvania said
we hold that when a prosecutor makes an
unconditional promise of non-prosecution
and when the defendant relies upon that
guarantee to the detriment of his
constitutional right not to testify
the principle of fundamental fairness
that under gerd's due process
of law in our criminal justice system
demands the promise be enforced
and so cosby was out of prison and and
he was freed the same day
as mallory points out this is good news
for defendants in pennsylvania who can
benefit from the court's broad
pronouncement
a defendant is entitled to relying
reasonably on promises a prosecutor
makes including as here
an insurance made in a public press
announcement of note
there didn't have to be an agreement
between the prosecutor and the defendant
the prosecutor just has to make an
assurance to the defendant that
the defendant then relies upon to his
detriment
and as the court pointed out if you felt
differently if you feel that the
defendant should then say to the
prosecutor i don't trust you
and so i'm not going to listen to you
i'm still going to invoke the fifth
amendment
this is now encouraging people not to
trust prosecutors which is precisely the
opposite of the result you wish to
obtain
okay so the entire world has gone crazy
about this because once again
they have gone to a bad man got out of
jail as opposed to the courts are not
interested
in whether somebody is good or bad the
courts are interested in the process of
due process
and this does run roughshod through our
system right now right now in the united
states there seems to be
and it is the prevailing notion that
neutral rights
can be dispensed with so long as we
don't like you and so long as we don't
like you rights should not apply to you
we see this in freedom of association we
see this in freedom of speech we see
this in due process
if you're brett kavanaugh and we have
decided we do not like you then due
process concerns are of no validity and
we should not be worried about them
at all a single accusation without any
supporting evidence should be enough
to get you tossed in terms of
consideration from the supreme court
if you are a person who
utters a a slur and this
really should not be enough to finish
your career
we still say you know freedom freedom of
speech really should not apply to you
freedom of speech shouldn't apply to you
because you said bad things well again
freedom of speech is a broad individual
right
and it does protect you it should
protect you and i'm not just talking
about legally here in terms of due
process you are talking legally when
you're talking about cosby i'm talking
about the
generalized perception that people
deserve a due process
which is both social and legal that
needs to be preserved
especially for people you don't like the
same thing is true a freedom of speech
and so called cancel culture right there
there does have to be
a generalized attitude that you're
allowed to say what you want to say
and that doesn't mean that people can't
react to you socially
it does mean the notion that free speech
is the danger which has been used as
sort of a club against social media
lately
and social media the left says is bad
because it allows people we don't like
to speak freely and so we should toss
donald trump for example from facebook
and from twitter
that's really dangerous stuff once you
start believing that rights that adhere
to you as an individual and pre-exist
government
no longer exists because we don't like
what you're saying
now you have entered the realm of
tyranny so
did bill cosby deserve on a moral level
to go free
bill cosby on a moral level deserves to
be in jail for the rest of his life
but on a legal level right and on a due
process level and on a societal level
bill cosby should not be in jail based
on the prosecution of his trial by the
way there are serious questions about
that trial with regard to allowing
some 19 women to testify against him on
the basis of prior experiences with him
outside the statute of limitations
harvey weinstein is going to make the
same case
so once again due process does have to
you do have to have some neutral laws
of neutral applicability or we can't
live together as a society it just turns
into pointing figure
fingers and who we decide is worse and
more guilty
that day okay in just one second when we
get to the worst
column of the day from the washington
post which does indicate where we are
going as a culture
and it does suggest that middle ground
is quickly disappearing
in the united states with regard to how
we view
social policies okay we'll get to that
in one second first
let us talk about the fact that sleep
quality ought to matter to you now when
i'm traveling
my sleep just isn't the same and the
reason for that is because i'm on a
generic mattress at some hotel well when
i'm at home i have a mattress that was
made just for me by the folks at helix
sleep
helix sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete it matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else well with helix you're
getting a mattress you know will be
perfect for the way you sleep because
you took a two minute sleep quiz and now
they're going to make a mattress that
really is customized so that you sleep
the best you have ever slept
everybody is unique helix knows that
they have several different mattress
models to choose from
they have soft medium firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot even a helix plus mattress
for plus size folks
so if you're looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you order the mattress
that you're matched to the mattress
comes right to your doorstep for free
you don't ever need to go to a mattress
store again helix is awesome but you
don't need to take my word for it helix
was awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 by gq and wired
magazine just go to helix sleep.com
ben take their two minute sleep quiz
they will match you to a customized
mattress that'll give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10 year warranty you get to try it out
for a hundred nights risk free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you absolutely will helix is
offering up to 200 bucks off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at helixsleep.com
that's helixsleep.com
all right well today marks the first day
of non-pride month which means that all
of the corporate logos go back to normal
all the corporations stop with their
woke virtue signaling
and uh they're not expected to keep up
with the woke virtue signaling so
you know i guess that pride is is over
and we're back to regular life is the
way that this this nonsense works
uh but not before the worst column of
pride month came out in the washington
post
is by a person named lauren roello a
writer who lives in the philadelphia
area
okay so this this person wrote a piece
in the washington post titled yes
kink belongs at pride and i want my kids
to see it
now i tend to be pretty libertarian
about things right when
i don't think the government should
really be in the business of compulsion
unless somebody is hurting somebody else
and this starts to get dicey when you're
talking about children
there is a battle that is brewing about
the future of our nation's kids
and it is unavoidable it is not
avoidable there is no libertarian
solution to it
okay the libertarian solution typically
which is let everybody do whatever it is
that they want
as long as they're not hurting anybody
else that libertarian argument ceases to
apply when you're talking about the
impact
on children who do not have the power of
consent do not have fully rational
characteristics are not capable of
making decisions
then we as a society have to decide what
the rules of the road are going to be
and this has come up in the context of
for example critical race theory
recently
where the right has said quite correctly
that children should not be
indoctrinated with the nonsense of
critical race theory which suggests
that racially essential characteristics
determine your value
and your perspective on matters of
politics and whether you have a chance
of success in the united states
kids should not be indoctrinated with
that it's a violation
of of children's ability to thrive and
it is in fact
a form of emotional and intellectual
child abuse
to teach kids that they are victimizers
or the victimized
okay so when it comes to kids we all do
have a fairly large say
in what the societal standard should be
because again there's a non-consenting
party who's now part of this bargain
the same thing holds true when it comes
to social policy so
the left has decided and this is again i
think an unavoidable battle that is
going to come to your town it is going
to come to your state
it's going to come to your household and
the unavoidable battle is you have a
group of people on the left
and they suggest that if you raise your
child in a traditional manner
if you raise your child to believe that
a traditional family structure is better
okay that a man and a woman raising a
child is better than a man and a man or
a woman and a woman
if you believe that men and women exist
and that these are not malleable
categories
and that a man cannot become a woman and
that if a child suffers from gender
dysphoria
you should participate in for example
watchful waiting
right you you should simply wait to see
how things develop
you should not give in to the delusion
that your child actually is a member of
the opposite gender the left believes if
you do that that's a form of child abuse
and cps should arrive at your door
don lemon on cnn literally yesterday
said that he believes
only the state should be involved in
adoption decisions presumably because he
likes
the state's perspective when it comes to
these matters of social politics
he thinks that churches should be taken
completely out of the business of
adoption
not because he doesn't like
quote-unquote churches per se but
because he doesn't like the perspective
of churches
which may adopt out to traditional
father mother families
and not to male male families female
female families single dads or single
moms
right so that is one perspective on the
raising of children
is that the social left ought to win and
then there's the perspective from the
right which is that children's innocence
when it comes to matters of sex
ought to be preserved that you are fully
not only justified but doing a good in
teaching your child traditional sexual
values
and teaching your child for example that
getting married to a member of the
opposite sex and producing natural born
children is more likely to produce
happiness
that if you teach your kid that you're
doing something good for them and that
if you indoctrinate them
into confusion and more importantly if
you sexualize children at a very young
age you are doing grave harm
not only to their psyche but also to
their emotional state
that perspective means that there will
have to be some protections for children
and these two
wildly varying perspectives are now
coming to a head and they're in direct
conflict and so
this column from the washington post is
indicative of that conflict
and it should awaken people who are sort
of softly in the middle
you know the silent middle that this
battle is is going
it is going to happen and the folks who
claim that they just want to live and
let live perspective
on how people raise their kids they're
mostly lying it really is not true
okay because the way that identity works
in the united states now
is based on emotivism identity is rooted
in the notion that if i deny
your perspective on your own identity
then i have participated in a harm
against you and i must be stopped this
is why you are seeing for example
an attempt to to it will come to the
united states by the way you've already
seen it in canada there's an attempt now
to go after parents
on the basis that they are not teaching
their children the state approved
messaging with regard
to gender and sexual orientation that's
going to come to the united states
because the perspective of the left is
you are doing great harm to a child
if you don't teach their their sort of
polyamorous perspective on how exactly
sexual matters should work if you don't
teach that to children if you don't
doctor and kids in that
and these two world views are clashing
and they're clashing when it comes to
kids they'll get to this actual column
in just one second because it is quite
indicative
of where the conflict actually lies and
how people on the radical left
tend to view children which is as sort
of tools to be manipulated
into the new sexual politics we'll get
to that in one second first let's talk
about the fact that if you've got a
medical problem you really should go get
it solved a lot of people wait around on
medical problems hoping they solve
themselves typically this is not what
happens with roman you get a free online
evaluation and ongoing care for erectile
dysfunction all from the comfort and
privacy of your home
a us licensed healthcare professional
will work with you to find the best
treatment plan
if medication is appropriate it ships
you free with two-day shipping the whole
process is straightforward and discreet
getting started is super simple just go
to getroman.com complete an online visit
today
take care of your ed without leaving
your home complete an online visit today
to connect with a healthcare
professional and get it taken care of
and some medical issues are kind of
embarrassing to talk about or you just
don't want to deal with them because
better not to think about them this is
not one of those medical issues and
you can get it taken care of quickly and
discreetly without having to embarrass
yourself in the process head on over to
getroman.com
right now you get 15 bucks off your very
first month of ed treatment
it's time to get that ed taken care of
remember get started today you save 15
bucks off your first order of ed
treatment that is g-e-t-r-o-m-a-n
dot com slash ben right now save 15
bucks off your very first month alright
so
now to this column in the washington
post which is astonishing again this is
printed
in a major one of the two biggest
american newspapers in terms of
influence and impact lauren writing
quote
our family often took the train into
philadelphia but as we rode across the
bridge to attend the city's pride parade
five years ago my wife's leg bounced
with a nervous jitter
she squeezed my hand worried that she
might run into a colleague or be
harassed by a stranger
my wife is trans and wasn't out at the
time so she typically only expressed her
authenticity in the privacy of our home
that morning she wore a green skirt and
light makeup brushing her hair all to
one side
even though we'd attended pride marches
and protests in previous years that they
was our first celebrating openly as a
family it's what we are talking about
now
is a male female couple in which the
male now identifies as female
okay so number one that is highly likely
to um to confuse children
okay that in and of itself okay but
beyond that they're now taking
their kid a small their small children
to a pride parade
in which you are celebrating sexual
activity that's what pride is
okay pride is not a mere question of
family structure it is a celebration of
particular types of sexual activity
because after all if it were just a
celebration of family structure then you
could have two brothers adopting a kid
or a brother and a sister
or a single mom right but that's not
what pride parades typically are about
as people have noted
people who have been to pride parades
and who cover pride parades understand
that pride parades
very often and almost entirely
the universality of pride parades
include sexual components to them
right that undoubtedly so children
should not be at these things adults
want to participate
you can make a libertarian argument
obviously and it's a libertarian
argument which i generally agree which
is this is not
a matter of compulsion however if you're
talking about children now you're
talking about non-consenting people
being put into sexual scenarios for the
pleasure of adults that's the only
reason you're bringing kids to this
thing
so this is what this mother writes when
our children grew tired of marching
we plopped onto a nearby curb just as we
got settled our elementary schooler
pointed in the direction of oncoming
floats
raising an eyebrow at a bare-chested man
in dark sunglasses whose black
suspenders clipped onto a leather thong
the man paused to be spanked playfully
by a partner with a flog
what are they doing my curious kid asked
as our toddler cheered them on
the pair was the first of a few dozen
kingsters who danced down the street
laughing together as they twirled their
hips and batons some leading companions
by leashes
at the time my children were too young
to understand the nuance of the
situation but i told them the truth
that these folks were members of our
community celebrating who they are and
what they like to do see the conflation
of who they are and what they like to do
is always a very interesting
identity driven notion right that who
you are is what you like to do it's the
same thing
it's it's you know there's an argument
to be made that that is not
that immutable characteristics do not
include flogging other men in public on
their on their bottom i mean i think
there
there's a fair notion that for example
if you're making the argument
that that gay rights are similar to to
race rights
um i i i'm spotting some
some differences there also i love that
she says my children are too young to
understand the nuance of this
what's the nuance exactly like really
i'm explains me the nuance
of men walking down the street spanking
each other on the bare bottom with flogs
in front of children
is there a lot of nuance there that i'm
missing i feel like not but according to
the left
this is nuanced education of children
according to the radical left
now i do want to differentiate again i
think there's a broad middle of the
country
particularly i know a lot of gay folks
who think that this is really terrible
that you should not be exhibiting kink
behavior in front of children
but the point is this the radical left
which is basically decided that all
human behavior ought to be treated
the same unless it's religious behavior
that all human sexual behavior also be
treated with equal levels of respect and
acceptability
and that children ought to be
indoctrinated into that belief it's hard
to argue against that principle
on the basis of a sort of lack of
fundamental understanding of natural law
according to the washington post's
columnist the kink community has
participated in pride since its
inception
risking their jobs and safety to be
authentically themselves in public see
it's all about authentically themselves
it's all about you
and we have to indoctrinate children to
accept your quote-unquote authentic self
and to celebrate your authentic self so
it's not about kids it's about you
it's about you feeling good about
yourself and indoctrinating kids in
order to
not focus on them leading a happy life
but in order to create a society in
which you
feel more welcomed and accepted this is
the perspective of the radical left and
they can't feel welcomed
and accepted unless your children too
participate in the celebration and the
acceptance
says this columnist in the washington
post i agree that pride should be a
welcoming space for children and teens
but policing how others show up doesn't
protect or uplift young children
instead homogenizing self-expression at
pride will do more harm to our children
than good when my own children caught
glimpses of king culture they got to see
that the queer community encompasses so
many more non-traditional ways of being
living and loving as much as i want them
to spend time in queer spaces so they
can be with families like their own
i also want them to know they shouldn't
limit their understanding of what
relationships or expression
expressions look like to their to
whatever's most familiar
i want them to see they can make their
own way in the world how else can they
learn about the scope and vitality
of queer life how uh how delightful
how delightful and this columnist
continues quote
children who witness king culture are
reassured that alternative experiences
of sexuality and expression are valid no
matter who they become as they mature
helping them recognize that their
personal experiences aren't bad or wrong
and they aren't alone in their
experiences
i can't think of a more relevant or
important reminder for youth who often
struggle with feelings of isolation and
confusion as they discover more about
themselves and wrestle with concerns
about whether they're normal enough
including kink in pride open space for
families to have necessary and powerful
conversations with young people about
health
safety consent and most uniquely
pleasure
kink visibility is a reminder that any
person can and should shamelessly
explore
what brings joy and excitement see
this is the the problem with the radical
left argument there are a lot of things
that we don't approve of as a society
that i'm sure bring a certain subset of
the population joy and excitement
and they are forbidden by law and well
they should be by the way sexualizing
children removes one of those barriers
but understand the case that this person
is making is not only
that we shouldn't ban kink at pride
parades it's that it is a fundamental
good for children to watch kink
at pride parade it makes it makes them
more open-minded it makes them more
accepting and of course we're really
protecting them
because you never know what weird stuff
they might be into and
if those kids who are five six four
years old if they turn out to be into
weird stuff which of course would never
be shaped by the environment in which
they're raised of course i mean
environment has nothing to do with this
it's completely genetic
kink is just completely genetic just
like everything else except for the fact
that it's not and there's no proof of
that but
it's it's completely so you don't have
to worry about your kids being affected
because you know they're just going to
be who they're going to be sexually of
course
all of this is designed at the
indoctrination of children
it's designed at the indoctrination of
children and and and
pushing what are behaviorally
abnormal standards on children and then
teaching
those children that the highest form of
good
is celebration of this it is sexualizing
children and by the way
you making like the the line from here
to pedophilia is
pretty straight i mean it's a pretty
straight line from it is good for kids
to watch kink so that they can explore
their own sexual feelings too
why can't they consent in actually
exploring their sexual feelings with
people
i mean why i mean children are sexual
beings too
if you can't see the line being blurred
here i'm not i mean they're literally
talking about children watching
kink parades i'm pretty sure that the
line from their pedophilia is real thin
says this columnist we don't talk to our
children enough about pursuing sex to
fulfill carnal needs that delight and
captivate us in the moment is that
really what we don't talk to our
children enough about
really that's that's what society is
lacking is it is is the pure pursuit of
carnal pleasure
and and speaking about it to small
children who are incapable
either of understanding it because they
haven't even hit puberty yet
or two even if they're teenagers making
solid decisions on that basis
they remove all moral lines and they're
gonna live a happier life seems to be
the
predominant notion and again what that
really is about is
people want to express adults want to
express their authentic selves and they
want children
to applaud them because they want
everybody to applaud them
that is not good okay i never want my
children to worry that exploring any
aspect of consensual sex or touch
is taboo real again
i'm gonna read that sentence slowly for
you because i don't understand
how this doesn't blur over into
pedophilia seriously i never want my
children to worry that exploring
any aspect of consensual sex or touch is
too taboo
if you have kids you're going to teach
them a lot
about what kind of touch is okay and
what kind of touch is not
but says this columnist if we're afraid
to talk about kink with our children we
prioritize the status quo
and here's the big issue right
sanitizing and censoring their access to
information about appropriate and normal
self-expression you're damaging the
children remember this is not just
i want to raise my child so i want to
raise my child which again would be
objectionable because your child can't
consent to how you're raising them
in a perverse way beyond that i mean
honestly in a in a decent society cps
would be on its way after reading this
column
child protective services would be
headed directly to this person's house
after reading this column
exposing children to men flogging each
other's bare bottoms in public
my goodness okay but that's not the
extent of this the extent is your child
should be exposed to this too it's that
your child is
is less and you're a you're a worse
parent for not exposing your kids to
this
these are the very attitudes that made
pride necessary and life affirming
for so many of us in the first place we
have no business imposing them on the
next generation
kink embodies the freedom pride stand
for stands for reminding attendees to
unapologetically
take up space as an act of resistance
and celebration refusing to bend to
social pressure that asks us to be
presentable
that's a value i want my children to
learn
okay well um this is child abuse and um
and the fact
that we as a society have decided that
this stuff is worthy of the pages of the
washington post says an awful lot about
the direction of our society because
everything
that people think is too radical and
far-fetched five years from now becomes
the law of the land
that seems to be the common pattern when
it comes to social
politics and sexual politics in the
nation
and once again we are going to reach a
point where americans just say no and
they should have said no
to a lot of this stuff long i mean once
it's reached the page of the washington
post
it is uh my goodness but the blowback is
coming and it's coming strong
and the more the left embraces this
stuff
do it like really i'd love to see it i
think the apathetic middle is not going
to remain apathetic for long when you
start telling them that their children
need to watch kink parades in order to
be more broad-minded
so they will not be judge because we
don't want them to be judgmental of
others and also because
they the children need to explore their
own kink sides
and the reason i'm spending a lot of
time on this is because it is indicative
of a consistent world view
there's a world view on the left that
says all sexual behavior is appropriate
and decent and good and also
that children should be taught it okay
and
again if you think all sexual behavior
is appropriate and decent and good
then why shouldn't children be taught it
after all in fact the worst thing you
could do is repress children in a
freudian sense
this is the this is the moral battle in
which parents are now engaged and you
wonder why people are moving from blue
states to red states you wonder why
people are seeking to protect their
children by taking them out of public
schools
and not subjecting them to the scrutiny
of state authorities
or more and more thinking like this
parent is thinking
and there's a phrase that my friend eric
erickson has used in the past he says
whatever is whatever is allowed
eventually becomes compulsory
right you will be forced to care
whatever is allowed becomes compulsory
in the end and that that is that is
exactly right when it comes to the
social left and its politics
you think right now this woman is just
saying i want to take my kid to a king
parade which is bad enough
eventually be you must take your kid to
a kink parade
because if you don't take your kid to a
king parade you're performing an act of
child abuse and you're undermining
social norms that accept kink behavior
that is the way it's going to go okay
and kink is just an outer edge example
of how this
has been a mainstream philosophy on what
for a very long time which is we need to
indoctrinate your kids
in k through 12 about the wonders of
lgbt lgbtq lifestyles and lgbtq morality
and the falsity of gender ideology and
we must indoctrinate them now we have to
do the same thing on race
at the left is not it's the left is not
willing to allow you to live and let
live
that middle libertarian perspective it
just doesn't exist when it comes to the
education of children the left knows it
the right better to get on to this real
fast
i think they're starting to okay in just
a second we're gonna get to joe biden
it seems as though he's flailing a bit
we'll explain why in just one second
first
let's talk about the fact that you don't
want to be standing in line at an auto
parts store it's not something
that you need to be doing why would you
you're going to stand in line get to the
front of the line finally
you get the part that you want and then
they're like oh yeah we don't have it
available we're ordering it it'll come
and then we're gonna
you know charge you up by like 25
instead why not just go to rockauto.com
and get the part you need
at the best price available rockauto.com
always offers the lowest prices possible
rather than changing prices based
on what the market will bear like
airlines do why spend up to twice as
much for the same parts
their family business serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years
go to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
the catalog is unique remarkably easy to
navigate quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle and choose
the brands specifications
and prices you prefer go to rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car or truck right shapiro in
there how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you again the
interwebs it's a wonderful thing and
rock auto allows you to avoid going to
the auto parts store and get the best
possible price instead head on over to
rockauto.com right now
and write your peer on there how did you
hear about usbox so they know that we
sent
you okay in today's america major
businesses pair at the ideological
chance of the left we saw that for an
entire month
when every major business in the united
states decided
that football for example is gay and
that
everybody must be crammed down last year
in the idea that that diversity training
you have to put the black square on your
instagram page or you find yourself
in the hr manager's office corporations
have been
cramming this stuff down on you it's not
just corporations it's every major
institution
in american society this is not going
away anytime soon
it is only growing under the current
administration we are experiencing what
i'm calling it the authoritarian moment
authoritarianism from the left they are
going to cram down on you how you should
parent your kid how you should live your
life
how you should operate your church this
is why my new book is called the
authoritarian moment it is an important
important book it is a book about how
every major institution in our society
was weaponized and militarized by a
a small contingent on the left how they
were able to renormalize institutions
and weaponize those institutions
against people who disagree and it's
really about how you can fight back
about how we can
look at the processes the processes that
the left used in order to cram down
their politics
on us and reverse those processes and
take back these institutions
so don't wait arm yourself with the
knowledge you need to shut the
cult down in its tracks before it's too
late the authoritarian moment is now
available for pre-order at amazon
barnes and noble or any other major
bookseller
also we have some excellent content
coming out for you this weekend too
often heroes don't receive the
recognition they deserve
for seven men who faded into the dryness
of the history books we'd like to change
that that's why we started a new podcast
called
america's forgotten heroes the first
episode is available today
this episode illuminates union soldier
joshua lawrence chamberlain who took his
place in history at the battle of
gettysburg by strategically charging the
confederates and narrowly dodging a
bullet that grazed his cheek on the way
his actions were pivotal to the union
winning that battle
but many americans don't know his name
if you fall into that category it's time
to remember it because men like
chamberlain are more than just men
they are legends and they are the reason
america is as free as it is today
subscribe now to america's forgotten
heroes on apple podcast spotify or
anywhere you might listen because the
first episode is out today thursday july
1st
one new action-packed episode drops each
day through the 4th of july weekend and
into next week
for a total of seven episodes because
too many heroes never receive the
recognition they deserve
sharing their stories with you on this
independence day it's our small tributes
to their heroism if you like what you
hear
leave a five star review help share
those incredible stories it gives it a
nice boost on the apple rankings thanks
for listening thank you to the heroes
that made such an excellent
podcast possible you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
meanwhile joe biden is slipping there's
a new poll out today from monmouth it
shows that joe biden's approval rating
which began at 54
with only 30 disapproving as of january
21st when he first took office he is now
down to 48
in the job approval rating down 6
percent and his disapproved numbers are
up 13
so he is slightly over water when it
comes to approval versus disapproval but
he is below 50
he's at 48 in the approval rankings his
ratings have slipped pretty
significantly over the course of the
last couple of months
among democrats according to monmouth he
slipped from 95 approval
in april to 86 in june 47
from independence in april to 36 now and
actually his numbers are slightly up
with republicans which is kind of
interesting according to monmouth but
that's not the only poll
that shows joe biden in trouble
according to reuters
president joe biden has seen an erosion
in support since april
there's another national poll out and it
shows again that his support among
democrats is dropping
a june 11th to 17th national opinion
poll shows biden is still more popular
than donald trump 55 of adults approving
of biden's
performance however the the numbers that
he has on specific issues suck
and there are a lot of people who are
who are really really concerned
about rising living costs for example a
majority of americans the public is
almost evenly split over how much the
government should do to make things
better
48 of respondents said they approved of
biden's handling
of the economy and again he is finding
himself sliding
among democrats the number of americans
who approved a biden stance on gun
violence dropped eight points overall 11
points among democrats from april to
june
he is he is losing some members of his
radical left
and so he's kind of stuck between a rock
and a hard place
and the problem is that joe biden
refuses to simply make the choice now
joe biden could have come into office
and been a highly popular president just
by not doing what he is doing namely
pursuing extraordinarily radical
policies that alienate half the
population
right in fact that is what he was
elected on the basis of
according to the new york times nate
cohen writing married men and veteran
households were probably not the
demographic groups
democrats assumed would carry the party
to victory over trump in the 2020
election
but joe biden's apparent strength among
traditionally moderate or even
conservative constituencies and
especially men
is emerging as one of the hallmarks of
his victory trump won married men by
just a 54 to 44
margin and that 20-point decline from
his 62-32
victory in 2016. he won veteran
households by a similar 55 to 43
margin but he won those same households
61 to 35
in the election cycle before that
in the in both cases the size of biden's
gains among those relatively
conservative groups rival
trump's publicized surge among latino
voters the new pull out by the way
showing 38
of latinos voted in favor of trump in
the last election cycle which is the
biggest number
in decades for republicans okay but
again what is incredible here is that
biden is ignoring what got him into
office
biden campaigned overtly as the not
bernie sanders candidate in the
primaries and then he campaigned again
as the guy who's going to restore
normalcy
and on that basis he won more moderate
and more conservative voters
and now his support is eroding among
democrats and among independents
and he's got a problem on his hands
because i'm not sure how he shores that
up
and spending more money ain't gonna
ain't gonna fix the problem now i think
the way that he wanted to shore that up
was with that bipartisan infrastructure
deal
but the problem there is that he's
afraid he's gonna lose bernie sanders on
his left
because bernie sanders has basically
said if you pass that infrastructure
deal without passing the reconciliation
bill maybe i'll sit this one out now i
don't believe bernie sanders
bernie sanders has never abstained from
a vote in which the government spends
more money
but biden feels like he is stuck between
a rock and a hard place
and meanwhile his policies are having a
pretty detrimental effect
on the country according to the new york
times
federal reserve officials spoke with one
voice throughout the pandemic downturn
promising that monetary policy would be
set to full stimulus mode until the
crisis was well and truly behind america
suddenly they are less in sync central
bankers are increasingly divided over
how to think about and respond to
emerging risks
after months of rising asset values and
faster than expected price increases
while their political counterparts in
the white house have been more unified
in maintaining
that the recent jump in price gains will
fade washington as a whole is wrestling
with how to approach policy
at a moment of intense uncertainty the
fed's top officials including chair
jerome powell acknowledge a lasting
period of uncomfortably high inflation
is a possibility
they've said it's more likely recent
price increases will fade as the economy
reopens
other officials have voiced more pointed
concern that the pickup in prices might
persist
they've suggested the fed might need to
stop the stimulus that's like james
bullard the president
of the federal reserve bank in st louis
so you've got conflict over inflation
which continues to rise at extraordinary
rates
you've got conflict over defunding the
police to the extent that the democrats
are now trying to walk
all this stuff back right jen saki has
now full bore
decided to dive into the lie that it's
republicans who are attempting to defund
the police that's how unpopular the
democrats position on policing has now
become among democrats and independents
they're now trying to blame republicans
for their own position here's jen saki
doing this ridiculous routine yesterday
the president ran and won the most votes
of any candidate in history on a
platform of boosting funding for law
enforcement
after republicans spent decades trying
to cut the cops program
there's record of that that doesn't
require anyone having new comments
and then also stood in the way of
crucial funding needed to prevent the
laying off of police officers as crimes
increased that's a simple statement of
fact i understand
what you're saying there however there
are lots of examples of democrats
explicitly saying
they want to defund the police i think
most people would argue that actions are
more important than words wouldn't you
say
when you say no i wouldn't say that if
you refuse to vote for a two trillion
dollar
boondoggle and that includes like one
good thing that you were against the
good thing that's a very silly way
of doing politics everybody understands
that the bible administration is stuck
if they disown their own radical
policies then the radical base gets
angry at them
if they don't disown their own radical
policies then the rest of the country
gets angry at them and the biden
administration is delusional if they
think that they ought to be relying on
the radical base more than they rely on
the moderates
again they're stuck in barack obama mode
thinking that the reason that they won
is because they cobbled together this
minority coalition and the minority
coalition pushed them to victory that is
not true the people who got biden
elected are suburban moms
they are married men they are military
households right those are the
those are demographically speaking the
constituencies that shifted their vote
pretty dramatically between 2016 and
2020. the reality is
that more black people on a percentage
basis voted for donald trump than
did in 2016 more hispanic people voted
on a percentage basis for donald trump
than they did in 2016. so biden is
aiming at completely the wrong
households
right he has a delusional view of what
got him where he is and now he is
following that
down the primrose path and meanwhile i
don't think even he knows what he's
doing at this point
i think i i would say that biden is of
divided mind but i don't even think that
he has a mind left
i mean he's he's just creepy as like i'm
sorry he is not with us
and everybody knows this which poses
another problem for the democrats the
only thing
holding this rickety ship together is
the fact that nobody finds joe biden
threatening
because if kamala harris were president
right now her approval ratings would be
in the low 40s
simple statement of fact joe biden is at
50 52 and the reason that he is at that
percentage
is because nobody finds him threatening
because they don't think he's alive
he seems to be a kind-hearted
daughtering old man who can't string
together three sentences in a row even
when reading from teleprompter
i mean here's joe biden is in a
consistent battle with the teleprompter
he's consistently fighting the
teleprompter and the teleprompter is
winning
hey here is joe biden versus the
teleprompter here we go
this job this jobs
the jobs that are going to be created
here
and joe biden is down he's down
teleprompter
standing over him dancing a victory
dance put the count on him
okay well when he's not fighting the
teleprompter joe biden is whispering
creepily into the microphone i don't
know who told him this is a good
political tactic
but again it sees a romero whispering
into the camera i think in order for us
to really feel the full effect of this
the camera needs to be tilted about 35
degrees
if it's still about 35 degrees so it's
just off kilter then this starts to
really make more sense here's joe biden
whispering like a crazy person into the
microphone again
people say well that's a giveaway hey
guys
i think it's time to give ordinary
people a tax break
the wealthy are doing fine i mean it
that's free how'd you like that coming
out at four o'clock in the morning
my goodness and meanwhile joe manchin is
out here going like
all you have to do is kind of do what
i'm telling you to do and you'll be fine
are you saying i don't understand why
you all want us to write checks that our
kids won't be able to cash
because it's very silly but joe biden
isn't working with mansion
and not working across the aisle instead
he has decided to under i mean
the one time he worked across the aisle
he decided to immediately within
two hours undercut his own message to
the point where the white house had to
walk it back
here is joe manchin repeating a message
that if joe biden actually said might
make joe biden slightly more popular
you put me anywhere you want to in the
political spectrum but i think i'm
pretty much
centrist in the middle where most people
are and pragmatic enough to figure
okay i understand you've identified the
need on this side
but we've already spent how many
trillions of dollars as
attending to a lot of those needs how
much more can we afford
do you want more debt i looked at this
morning we're 28
almost 0.5 trillion dollars of debt how
much more can we add on stephanie how
much more can we pass on to your
children
the next generation we've always said
we're writing checks
our kids can't cash okay but elizabeth
warren says we're never going to have to
cash those checks because who cares
and that is a battle inside the
democratic party it is not going to end
anytime soon
it's actually getting worse like a lot
worse which is why for example
representative james clyburn
is now opposing an ally of bernie
sanders in a special election in
cleveland there's a major battle that is
broken out inside
the democratic party here here i mean
it's
it's astonishing on tuesday clyburn took
aim at one of sanders's most outspoken
acolytes nina turner a hero to the left
who's surging in her campaign in ohio to
claim
the congressional seat vacated by marcia
fudge clyburn
is now endorsing chantel brown turner's
leading opponent
he said the reason is because this is
the slogan earring of the party's left
flank
which is dangerous okay all that is
masking this is the presence of joe
biden it's all that is masking this
at this point maybe because again joe
biden's not there and he doesn't seem
super threatening so everybody's like oh
okay fine so is he radical as you matter
he cares he's barely alive
meanwhile kamala harris is waiting in
the wings and democrats are panicking
they're just panicking because
every time kamala harris appears on
camera you know it's going to get bad
and so you're starting to see the apple
research dumps
it's unbelievable actually kamala harris
you would think is
in a sort of impregnable position that
if joe biden were to plot
or if he were to not run in a couple of
years
you would think that kamala harris would
be the obvious heir parent i mean he's
been not only campaigning with her
he brings her out randomly at events as
though she's the co-president as opposed
to
occupying the office that is a warm
bucket of spit
right and so it's very weird he's giving
her these big
these sort of big portfolios like the
border like these high-profile
portfolios climate change
and then she's terrible at it and so
what you're starting to see is rebellion
against kamala harris inside the
democratic party there's and
pure oppo being dropped on her today in
politico there is a piece
called not a healthy environment kamala
harris office rife with dissent
okay now we know that kamala harris her
office is a bleep show there's an entire
article in the new york times when she
first
dropped out of the presidential race
before iowa
talking about how it was completely
dysfunctional she couldn't run in office
she was a terrible candidate
and then of course as soon as biden
picked her she became the greatest
candidate in the history of the world
why did we ever do that to kamala why
and well now there's a piece in politico
and the oppo is starting to come out
turns out nobody likes kamala
when vice president kamala harris
finally made the decision to visit the
mexico border last week
people inside her own office were
blindsided by the news for days
aides and outside allies had been
calling and texting with each other
about the political fallout a potential
trip would entail
but when it became known that she was
going to el paso and left many
scrambling including officials who were
responsible for making travel
arrangements and others
outside the vp's office charged with
crafting the messaging across the
administration
the handling of the border visit rights
politico was the latest chaotic moment
for a staff that's quickly become mired
in them
harris's team is experiencing low morale
porous lines of communication diminished
trust among aides and senior officials
much of the frustration internally is
directed to tina florinoy harris's chief
of staff
a veteran of democratic politics who
began working for her earlier this year
in interviews 22 current and former vp
aides
administration officials and associates
of harrison biden described a tense and
at times dower atmosphere
aids and allies had fluorinoid in an
apparent effort to protect terrorists
has instead created an insular
environment where ideas are ignored or
met with harsh dismissal
dismissals and decisions are dragged out
often they said she refuses to take
responsibility for delicate issues and
blames staffers for the negative results
that causes while much of the ira is
aimed at harris's chief two
administration officials said the vp
herself also bears responsibility for
the way her office is run
it all starts at the tops of one of the
administration officials people are
thrown under the bus
from the very top there are short fuses
it's an abusive environment it's not a
healthy environment people often feel
mistreated it's not a place where people
feel supported
it's a place where people feel treated
like bleep man the oppo coming out on
kamala harris this early
they are in serious trouble the
democrats are in trouble they know
they're in trouble and they can't
they cannot direct that car away from
the cliff they can't they are stuck
between a rock and a hard place and
kamala is waiting in the wings and
they're trying preemptively to dump her
and it ain't gonna work
if you're a republican i mean just focus
on talking about the democrats that's it
they're the easiest pickings
in in years it's truly an amazing site
to watch them implode this way
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of the ben
shapiro show coming up soon is the matt
wall show airs at 1 30 pm eastern be
sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pablo wydowski
associate producer bradford carrington
host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam sci events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matte
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture faith current events
all the fundamentals if they matter to
you come check out the show